oh hisse mme la maison blanche qui par
ailleurs tente de faire taire les
critiques concernant le statut et les
conditions d'emprisonnement des 680
détenus de guantanamo des images
proposées par le panel tago nos chaînes
américaines pour montrer que les
prisonniers capture en afghanistan sont
bien traités et julien colombani ils
sont détenus à guantanamo le bagne par
excellence non ils peuvent jouer au
football c'est l'armée américaine elle
même qui le montre une prison modèle la
nourriture est saine le pain est frais
cinq fois par jour
le muezzin appelle à la prière les
détenus pratiquer leur religion sans
entre à la lecture du coran est permise
c'est d'ailleurs l'un des seuls ouvrage
autorisé ces images complaisamment
fournies par les autorités de washington
veulent prouver que l'amérique est bonne
fille elle traite bien ses pires à nu
peut-être mais combien de temps encore
vont ils devoir attendre leur procès le
problème à guantanamo n'est pas un
problème lié aux conditions matérielles
d'incarcération de cette population
le problème reste entier les deux ordres
à la fois juridique et puis aussi le
véritable problème c'est de voir que ces
gens là sont détenus depuis plus de deux
ans maintenant et qu'ils sont laissés
pour une durée serait semblablement
indéterminée que ce soit les prisonniers
du quartier de moyenne sécurité en blanc
ou ceux du quartier de haute sécurité en
orange presqu'aucun des 680 détenu de
guantanamo n'a le statut de prisonnier
de guerre
ils sont gardés au secret sans
possibilité de se défendre sans savoir
quel sera leur sort de toute autre image
elle date d'il ya deux ans lorsque les
premiers combattants talibans arrivent
et enchaîné sur la barre aujourd'hui les
rares organisations humanitaires qui ont
eu un droit de visite s'inquiète de la
détérioration de la santé mentale d'un
grand nombre de prisonniers beaucoup se
mutilent des dizaines ont tenté de se
suicider